farò un posto strano è un posto strano
perché sicuramente un posto unico al
mondo e tutte le persone che vivono a
roma sentono questa unicità ne sono
terribilmente orgogliosi ma sono anche
strutturalmente critiche rispetto al
luogo in cui abitano nel corso del tempo
di questa unicità si è data
un'interpretazione profondamente
sbagliata secondo me perché si è
immaginato l'unicità semplicemente
neller interculturale che questa città
dimenticando fatto che grida culturale è
la produzione contemporanea di alcuni
colosseo quando hanno fatto era arte
contemporanea architettura contemporanea
e rita e si è immaginato di sostituire
diciamo i settori che avevano guidato la
crescita economica del dopoguerra
sostanzialmente col consumo della città
da parte del turismo per questo è
successo diciamo fine degli anni novanta
in buona sostanza metà del 2000 questo
però l'interpretazione profondamente
distorta della città nel senso che roma
è un posto in cui non solo c'è uno
straordinario patrimonio culturale
alberga circa 50 per cento le ricerca
scientifica pubblica tra tutti i vertici
un corpo accademico composto da oltre
250 mila studenti 40 università e
settori di produzione
culturale contemporanea industriale e
non industriale molto vivaci questo la
politica
dal mio punto di vista per essere
qualcosa di profondamente diverso da ciò
che noi vediamo ma questo richiede un
cambiato un cambiamento che è prima di
tutto nei nella testa delle persone ed è
un cambiamento che riguarda solo ma però
vorrei provare a spiegarlo molto
brevemente io penso che non penso
veramente che roma per ragioni non posso
spiegare qua perché è un lungo ma anche
per la caratteristica degli spazi fisici
tanto più nel momento in cui compare
mobilità assistita è un luogo in cui con
l'eccezione leo non è stata costruita
per le macchine sul pezzo storico la
città a certe dimensioni è un posto in
cui seriamente si può ragionare su un
funzionamento della città che sia molto
più vicine ai partiti la sostenibilità
di altre città vuole varos mano è molto
più complicato e viene fuori imperiali a
questo punto it per piemme una però io
me lo domando a roma lo domando ma come
come si fa a fare la sostenibilità se
noi siamo tutti quanti
spinti a competere invece recuperare a
essere indifferenti e sospettosi invece
di essere empatici a essere
disinteressati superficiali che invece
di essere curiosi ad essere cinici e
malfidati invece di avere fiducia che
l'altro con cui possiamo stare insieme è
una parte del nostro stare insieme a
essere comunità si fa la sostenibilità
se l'aspirazione massima a cui siamo
spinti e quella di consumare di più di
quello che ci sta vicino
come si fa a fare la sostenibilità se la
misura del successo della sostenibilità
è quanto spendiamo non per che cosa
e neanche come misuriamo quello che
facciamo ma che non produciamo scambio
denaro alla malattia e le cure fanno il
pil una persona in buona salute che
corre non lo fa il pil non lo fa la
qualità morale non lo fa il
funzionamento della pubblica
amministrazione non fanno più queste
cose qua come si fa a fare la
sostenibilità se noi non usciamo da
questo paradigma e questo paradigma è
funzionale a un modello economico che
prevede il consumo
l'aumento nel consumo con condizione del
suo sviluppo
il capitalismo finanziario come lo
conosciamo noi è incompatibile con la
sostenibilità eccola la realizzazione
diritti umani senza l'emancipazione
delle persone non c'è la sostenibilità
quindi il problema di fondo è in che
modo attraverso gli strumenti
individuali ma collettivi quindi del
governo si riesce a contrastare un
fenomeno che è globale anche nel governo
delle città e faccio un esempio per così
ci capiamo
noi oggi abbiamo i centri storici di
tutte le città belle del mondo che sono
spogliati di qualunque funzione tranne
la funzione di consumo del centro
storico per effetto del turismo e pezzi
interi di città che sono trasformati in
luoghi incomprensibili in ragione del
fatto che c'è una forma di speculazione
immobiliare che è funzionale alla
costituzione di patrimonio scambiabile
sui mercati finanziari
noi in italia non possiamo alzare l'imu
al di sopra di un certo livello
perché c'è un vincolo di legge la legge
stabilisce che l'imu all'imposta diciamo
sul patrimoniale sugli immobili
quindi nel momento in cui oggi il covip
si fa vedere in modo finalmente che c'è
un problema nel centro storico della
città e il problema è oggi vissuto da
chi ha sviluppato attività economiche
del centro città per servire i turisti
c'erano 130 mila persone giorno medio
che non ci sono più la risposta che
generalmente si cerca dare benissimo io
aumento la capacità di erogare servizi
da parte queste attività commerciali
l'aumento dei tavolini no ma i 130.000
persone non ci sta e posso dire che
forse adesivi desiderabile che non ci
siano più centrale mio 130 mila persone
al giorno medio nel centro della città
se io voglio recuperare centro la città
ha delle funzioni a un uso da parte di
tutta la collettività ma per fare questo
vuol dire che io devo cambiare le
condizioni che rendono vantaggioso a chi
ai proprietari delle unità immobiliari
per gli utilizzi e quelle funzioni io
questi strumenti no io lug no look a
bergamo veramente noi questi strumenti
non ce l'abbiamo e peraltro non ci sono
gli orientamenti generali per scontrarsi
con interessi sono interessi di
carattere gigantesco come si fa a questa
roba come si fa a uscire da un modello
che è globale oggi e che spinge ciascuno
di noi ci domanda di consumare si regge
sul fatto che noi siamo consumatori
paradossalmente se lo guardiamo diciamo
nelle piattaforme digitali addirittura
noi siamo la merce liceo neanche più
consumatore nel nostro tempo è la merce
che viene venduta
sui social media allora questo richiede
una disponibilità a un ragionamento sui
quindici minuti che fa moreno della
città dai quindici minuti è un
ragionamento che modifica
sostanzialmente le condizioni che
consentono l'atterraggio dei capitali
finanziari all'interno delle aree urbane
ma ci avete presente cosa significa fare
quella cosa al netto di dirlo in una
città ma questo significa fare che
nascondevano nasce secondo me il covip
ci dimostra che possono nascere delle
alleanze dei progetti politici che hanno
una radicalità che noi non abbiamo visto
oggi è un pragmatismo che fino a oggi
non abbiamo visto i cui soggetti
principali sono i governi delle città
nelle grandi aree urbane
perché quelle luogo in cui la tensione
tra la realizzazione delle condizioni
materiali e morali che consentono alle
persone di sviluppare quelle
caratteristiche ritengono cittadini
sostenibili e gli interessi che spingono
nella direzione esattamente opposta di
questo naturalmente nel governo
ordinario città non riesce mai a parlare
perché stai mettono sempre a parlare no
anche perché i media ti parlano del vano
della buca che pure esiste ovviamente
labardi scorretto ma di questa scala i
problemi sono il contributo che le città
possono dare come war come formazione
sociale a questa corsa urgente e da
questo punto di vista è cruciale che le
persone siano consapevoli del ruolo
fondamentale che i governi delle aree
urbane hanno in questa partita